[MUSIC]
I read the letter.
>> Oh my gosh.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> I think I started screaming.
>> As soon as I read the word,
congratulations, I just stop reading.
>> My mom was with me,
we were both cheering.
>> It was just like dream come true.
>> For me personally,
I wanted to study business but
with a more technological edge.
>> I'm learning industry level skills,
that's a headstart, that's an advantage.
>> My parents were with me on Move-In day.
>> I still miss them everyday and
my brother.
I can't forget you.
[LAUGH]
>> They got to see where I was going and
they could have faith that
I was at a good place.
>> Orientation week
definitely helped a lot.
>> Don't be afraid to explore.
>> Ask questions.
>> Meet as many people as you can.
>> My best friends were
from orientation week.
>> I had to tell myself
to just soak it all in.
Just embrace the awkward.
>> My best advice to you is-
>> Go to an event as soon as you find one.
>> Work hard but also play hard.
>> If you want to try something new go for
it, if that doesn't work out then try for
something else.
>> There's so many possibilities.
>> Build Hackathon.
>> Fraternities and sororities.
>> B Flat Singers.
>> Even the ballroom dance
team if you're interested.
>> Community service is a way for
me to take a step back,
look at what's going around
me not just at myself.
>> What I really get my memories
from are these extracurriculars and
the friends that I've made.
>> You're among the brightest people.
>> We're all driven and
we're also passionate.
There's just really a sense
of cooperativeness.
>> There are always people around
who are gonna support you.
>> The faculty have always been there for
me.
I can go to them after class and
just talk to them.
Not even just about class, but about life.
>> That's the culture of CNU.
I'm an advocate.
>> I'm an entrepreneur.
>> I'm a code breaker,
because I break all my code.
>> If you're afraid of making mistakes,
don't be.
>> All of my successes come after failure.
How you pick yourself up
is what's really important.
>> CNU has made me
a completely different person.
>> When I walk across campus,
I feel like I'm at home.
>> There's a lot of space here for
creativity, for excitement.
>> People are building, creating.
>> Anything is possible.
>> Don't be afraid to
diverge from you path.
>> Whatever you do, just give your all,
no matter what the outcome might be.
My heart is in the work.
>> My heart is in the work.